it is true that using a fixed-width
viewport means that your content is
almost always going to be scaled and not
match the native resolution and
definitely in some cases users are going
to have to zoom to be able to see or
read anything particularly text since
everything will scale depending on the
size of the screen fitting the current
layout precisely into the users screen
whether it's a forage phone or a 12 inch
tablet but actually your text and UI
will not change at all on the desktop
because currently at least non mobile
browsers don't respond to the viewport
at all in some cases of course it's the
right thing to do if you just want to
get the UI to fit on the screen to use
fixed width viewport like in my synth
app but of course those dials are
awfully small which makes the UI very
hard to use